(ominous, heavy music)
- [Voiceover] Are you ready?
Okay, good afternoon ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to Brooklyn, Wisconsin.
We're about to start the
competition here today,
and anytime you guys are ready to pull,
well you go ahead and
pull and never mind me.
- Steady!
(ominous music)
(grunting)
- [Voiceover] Tighter!
- [Voiceover] Tug-O-War is
the ultimate team sport.
If one man goes down,
he can take the whole team down with him.
'Cause you have to have
eight pullers workin'
in unison, as one.
- [Voiceover] Keep that,
keep that, keep that!
- [Voiceover] Push! Push!
(grunting)
- To the general public,
they think Tug-O-War may be just a game
in high school.
- Low, keep it low!
- In serious competition,
there are strict rules
and guidelines, and only the top athletes
in the countries get to that level.
- Center, keep it on the center.
- [Voiceover] Keep her down, boys.
Keep her down!
- [Herb] If you're goin' into a rope pull,
you might be the strongest
person in the world,
but if your head isn't in it,
you're gonna lose.
(grunting)
- [Voiceover] Push! Push!
- [Voiceover] (mumbling)
Cut it back! Cut it back!
Keep it there! Keep 'em back!
- [Voiceover] Back to positions, guys!
There you go. There you go! (mumbling)
(sighing)
- [Voiceover] Good job, guys.
(fast piano music)
- [Herb] Your legs are the
strongest muscles in your body
and they can push 400 pounds, easy.
And you gotta transfer
that through your hands.
They're not allowed to wear gloves.
They can only put the tack on.
Calluses build up.
I call 'em square fingers,
'cause you get the edges pushed.
I got involved with
Tug-O-War when I was drunk.
I was at a softball tournament,
and a friend of mine from high
school said they were short
and needed an extra puller.
And I said, "Okay."
I've been pulling ever since.
(somber, heavy music)
- Try it again.
Set!
- Well, the reason that
Tug-O-War was ousted
from the Olympics is that
they were cutting sports,
so they dropped it.
And that's been the fight:
to get it back in.
- [Voiceover] Push!
- [Herb] I hope to see
it back in the Olympics
'cause I believe it deserves to be there.
I'm representing the US,
and I take a lotta pride in
trying to do the best job
I possibly can.
- [Voiceover] Push! Push!
Push!
(heavy breathing)